هذا واحد من عشرات الفنادق التي تستخدمها
الحكومه البريطانيه لايواء طالب اللجوء
منعتنا الاداره من التصوير داخله وصلت
للبريتانيا بواسطه الشاحنه
عزيز وهو اسم مستعار مقيم في هذا الفندق
منذ وصوله الى بريطانيا في ديسمبر عام
2020 اي احباط نفسي يعني يعني
كلش لا انسانيه اي قرار وخاصه لشخص مثلي
واني 51 سنه هذا اندلت على شيء فيدل على
فشل الحكومه البريطانيه في في
حمايه
اعطاء اللاجئين حقوقهم تقول الحكومه انه
من غير العدل لدافع الضرائب البريطاني ان
يتحمل الفاتوره الباهظه لاستضافه اللاجئين
في فنادق
طلبات اللجوء تراكمت وهذه مشكله لدى
الحكومه العمل الماضي مثلا وصل البلاد
عشرات الالاف من طالب اللجوء واصدرت
الحكومه قرارات اوليه قالت ثلث حالات
الواصلين تقريبا
تتضمن خطط الحكومه اسكان طالبي اللجوء في
عوامات وقواعد عسكريه سابقه ومنها قاعده
ويذرز فيلد التي نقلت تبعيتها بالفعل من
وزاره الدفاع الى وزاره الداخليه التي
اوصدت ابوابها امام الكاميرات قاعده
لندن واحده من ثلاث قواعد عسكريه سابقه
تعتزم الحكومه البريطانيه استخدامها
لايواء طالب اللجوء اضافه الى موقع رابع
على الساحل الجنوبي كما تعتزم الحكومه
استخدام عوامات وقوارب لذات الغرض حتى
الان تم الاعلان عن استئجار عوامه واحده
على الاقل سترسوا في ميناء بورتلاند جنوبي
البلاد
انفاق كل هذه الاموال على الفنادق سببه
اساسا اخفاق الحكومه توقفوا عن هدر الوقت
واصدر قرارات في هذه الطلبات واخرج الناس
من الفنادق واسمحوا لهم بالعمل واعاده
بناء حياتهم
لكن الحكومه تسعى لاصدار تشريع يسمح
بترحيل طالب اللجوء الى رواندا الى اجل
البث في طلباتهم وهذا ما يراه معارضون
وحقوقيون نقطه سوداء في سجل حكومه
المحافظين تضاف الى نقاط اخرى منها وفاه
طالب لجوء مؤخرا في احد المراكز الحكوميه
ومنها فضيحه اختفاء عشرات الاطفال غير
المصحوبين من طالبي اللجوء من فنادق
وضعتهم فيها حكومه بلاد لجاوا اليها طلبا
للامن اسد الله الصاوي الجزيره لندن